And then Smith, the little that he is, believes me. And then
he goes around telling everybody, "Oh, Mr. Girl's protecting
me." But everybody knows that actually he's just a loser and
I don't like him. Is that your theory? Just say it. Just say
that. It's so much shorter than all this. Do you think Do you
think that if a baby somebody on a train while they're falling
off of a cliff that it's technically a boundary if you stop them?
Who's that for? Just say what you think. >> I think what
if you got to know the person who's that you are sucking better
to the point where they're not just a person and they're more
humanized because they're more threedimensional to you. She's
like actually incapable of following the conversation. Like actually
just completely incapable. This is like this is like watching
like a deaf person respond to somebody. Like they g they're handed
a script and they're deaf. She can't actually hear anything Max
is saying and she's just like she's trying to like lip read but
she can't actually lipre and then she's just responding with
like the closest thing she can think of off of her script. That's
>> You think I watched wasn't? >> Yeah. I've come
to you with a very important topic. >> Um, you watched
my talk with Smith. >> Uh, I watched part of your conversation
with Smith. Well, you DM'd me during it and told me to that he
needed me. But yes, I watched part of your conversation with
Smith and then I said that you were sociopathically trying to
trigger him and then bait me into coming on to your stream. uh
by triggering. >> Do you know the background about this?
>> the background is in the Smith food shops call? I have
no idea. >> No, the Smith and Mr. Girl thing. >> Like
what do you mean the background? That like Smith was just a super
obsessed viewer for a while. >> He feels like he's ostracized
from Max that Max is like um >> Oh, I am kind of aware
of this. No, no, no. I think well I think isn't Max's opinion
isn't Max's opinion that Smith has like an unhealthy obsession
with him and that he's trying to push like trying to push Smith
into like a healthy >> something like that. Yeah, Max is
like having boundaries and Smith feels like they are um he feels
neglected or being pushed away or something like that like not
acknowledged.
Um it's just weird. >> Smith is 30. BB Poison. There's
no way Smith looks so young. Well, I mean, he doesn't look like
incredibly young, but he just it's like the energy of a young
person.
I would have thought like 26 for Smith. Maybe 25. >> So,
I didn't watch the food shop and Smith talk, but it sounds like
it's it probably has to do with that. If Max feels like she tried
to bait Max into coming on after she like antagonized
>> Oh, he's 24. Okay. All right.
Um, Kilo, if you have a better explanation of what's going on
with Smith and Max, I'll read it off here. I'll go back. I'll
give you a second. >> Kilo might know better than me, >> but
yes, I watched part of your conversation with Smith and and then
I said that you were sociopathically trying to trigger him and
then bait me into coming on to your stream uh by triggering Smith
about his relationship with me, which uh it felt a little like
destiny. It was reminded me of old times. Yeah. >> To trigger
people enough to bring another person on. >> Yeah. just
creating this like vortex of people being stressed out about
what's being said or what's being said about them or how they
misrepresented themselves and wanting to come back on and fix
it or address things or oh this person's upset with you. You
got to come on or if something bad's happening you have to. >> Apparently
Smith is at least 29 or 30. A bunch of other people are saying
>> get on my stream and fix it. That kind of thing. >> It
was a It was a joke. A half joke. >> It's not a joke.
>> It was a half joke. >> No, I don't think so. I
think you're genuinely trying to get me to come on your stream
and triggering Smith as a way to uh accomplish this. >> How
was I triggering Smith? >> It doesn't matter. >> I
don't see me getting really.
>> Okay. How How were you doing it exactly? I don't even
remember the conversation. I think that you were telling him
that he doesn't have a relationship with me and that it's all
in his head and that he's embarrassing himself and that he should
take a break from social media or something like that. >> All
right, hold on. I'll read this. Kilo, the kilo messages in Smith.
Smith wrote a letter to Mr. Girl on the Reddit talking about
how hard it is to be a Mr. Girl fan because he constantly has
to downplay it. People criticized the letter for being parasocial
and cringe. Then Fu Jobs and Smith had a convo about the letter
where she tried to trap him into admitting that he was being
inappropriate and seemed disinterested in the convo and tried
to get Mr. Girl to join. It was rather weird. Okay, >> wait.
But Kilo, wasn't he upset that Max didn't engage with his letter
and then Max thought that like his letter was too much or his
post or whatever? >> How do you define boundaries? dragging
Kilo to talk. I mean, I can if he wants to come and explain this.
I don't see him in the discord, though.
>> Max did engage with his letter and Max absolutely did
not think it was too much. I don't know about the letter. I thought
it was before this letter. I thought it was some of the things
that Smith had said or something that although I to be fair,
I might be
>> Well, I might be thinking of Max's recollection or sorry,
Smith's recollection of what he thought Max was thinking. Kilo,
what's up? >> Oh, hey, can you guys hear me? >> Yep.
Yeah. So just all it was this is not pertaining to older about
Smith and Mr. Girl and Paris and stuff. This is specifically
about >> Smith and Fujop's conversation about the letter
that he wrote to Mr. Girl on the
>> But there was a thing about parasociality with Max and
Smith. >> I think with other people I I really don't perceive
based on what I've seen about it and based on what Mr. Girl says
about it that Mr. Girl is in any way like uncomfortable
or that Smith is like breaching some sort of boundary. Like I
don't like that's not really a component of it. I don't think
>> I'm not going that extreme, but I swear I've seen Smith
go on other streams and talk about it.
>> Yeah, Smith does. Yeah, he does talk about um what it's
like to be a fan of I >> and feeling like Max is like doing
them a disservice or doing him a disservice. >> He talks
about >> neglecting him or something. >> Uh not not
really with neglecting him though, but with like So obviously
you guys saw earlier in the um when was it? I think he was talking
to Emry a little bit about this stuff. Maybe not, but um he's
talking about like setting boundaries um with his fans. Um he
turned off his super chats. He doesn't take, you know, money
from kick and JT said like, "Yeah, of course this is very in
line with his personality, right?"
Um >> I Yeah, sure. Like I I knew he shut off the super
chats on his website. >> Yeah. So all this stuff is like
he's very concerned with exploitation of his fans and parasitiality
and setting boundaries and all these kinds of things. Um,
so the the conversation
between him and Smith often is Smith trying to indicate that
he understands why the boundaries are in place, but still talks
about how he struggles with like kind of wishing they weren't
there and things like that, but I don't think I don't think Max
is ever uncomfortable with it. I think he's fine with Smith expressing
himself in this way. >> Okay. Um, and then the conversation
between Smith and Food Shops just
people responded really negatively to the letter that Mr. or
sorry just hold on hold on >> I have a TTS playing just
okay >> sorry I had a TTS playing it was cutting you off
there can you just restart so the stream can hear you >> yeah
so Smith wrote a letter to Mr. Girl on the on the Reddit obviously
and the letter is essentially it's like two paragraphs long it's
like not like a super long thing um he's just talking about how
it's difficult to be a fan of Mr. because it kind of um he kind
of to other people has to pretend like he's not a Mr. Girl fan
and that it's difficult for him to actually access how he feels
about like his favorite creator and stuff like that. Um kind
of like weird stuff that people I think don't normally think
of, but like it kind of makes sense when you really dissect it.
And um and so then food shops brought on Smith to talk about
this like a couple days later after a bunch of people that Reddit
thread blew up and a bunch of people were just calling Smith
a freak and super parasocial and obsessed and all these things.
and Fujaf basically brought on Smith.
She seemed like she was fairly disinterested in the conversation.
She seemed like she was trying to corner him into admitting that
he was obsessed and breaching Mr. Girl's boundaries and all these
kinds of things. And um it seemed super contrived and like she
didn't really want to be there. And then she tried to DM Mr.
Girl and get him on at some point. So that's specifically what
he and food shops are talking about right now. >> Okay.
Uh thank you for the summary that you're welcome. >> Yeah.
I guess I said this I think right before you hopped on, but I
I said like, "Oh, I might be recalling Smith's recollection of
this and not Max's," which I guess would be in line with what
you were saying that Smith says it's like occasionally said like
he feels like Max is being distant. He feels like Max is pushing
him away,
right? That's like his feeling. Probably if I'd listened longer,
I don't think I've listened to a lot of Smith's stuff, but if
I'd listen longer, he'd probably say something like, "Oh, I realize
that's not actually the case." And like I sort of understand
what he's going for. But >> yeah, I don't know how much
they go into it because obviously they know what each what each
other are talking about, but um I didn't want it to be a thing
where you guys were thinking that they were talking about anything
other than the Reddit letter and stuff like that.
>> Thank you. >> Cool. Thanks. >> See you.
I just got to switch headphones real quick, guys, and then we'll
I'll hit play. >> Welcome back, Wolf Gang. You know what?
Never mind. >> Okay. Should be >> Well, I'm sorry.
I was I was in the bathroom while he was talking about
>> Yeah, sorry. I had to run back cuz I didn't want to
be rude. >> Oh, okay. I thought you were out of breath
from the bathroom.
>> No, no, no, no. Jesus. No, no. Sorry. Just ran
as quick as I could. All right. Okay. Hit and play.
>> Ready to go.
>> Ready to go. >> It feels as though that
boundaries are typically set by the person whose boundaries are
being crossed. >> Oh, yeah. Those mouth noises were me
just like clicking my tongue. That's all it is. I do that when
I'm sitting in silence. No. >> Uh, okay. You're referring
to Smith's assertion that I protect him from myself because we
have an unequal relationship and I have boundaries around that
relationship that are designed to protect him. Is that what you're
referring to? >> One watcher, you are triging the [__]
out of me. I've done this since I was a small child. Okay. Not
everything is just being like destiny. Were you the one who gave
Smith his boundaries?
>> Was I the one who gave Smith his boundaries? I wouldn't
say they're his boundaries. If they if I'm doing something to
protect him, but he didn't tell me to do it, that's my boundary.
>> Okay. So, and that specifically is to not be closer
to you. >> I think that you are playing a little trick
here with the definition. So, if I have a baby and I say, "Somebody
tickles the baby." And I'm like, "The baby's trying to eat. Don't
tickle the baby." Now, whose boundary is it? Is it my baby or
am I protecting the bound the baby's boundary? Well, I'm kind
of setting a boundary on behalf of the baby. Is it still a boundary?
Yes. Is it mine? Is it the babies? Well, it's mine that I'm enforcing
on behalf of the baby. So, it's kind of shared. >> Okay.
I think it might be a
semantic disagreement because
when I think of boundaries, I think of okay, there are >> a
level of
food shops, Will and his dead channel, and Katie are stupid.
Waste of space, waste of oxygen. >> All right, thank you
for the thank you for the $5 super chat, doobie. I don't have
any way to get my super chats through you guys in the
>> in the Discord. So, I don't know if it's the doobie.
Okay. Might not be the doobie, but it was somebody who donated
under the name of Dubbie. >> Thank you. >> Literally,
nobody else would try to be >> All right. >> Feelings.
What? What? What are these? >> What are what talking about?
>> Mr. Girl in Food Shops or what? I just want to be sure
that I'm, you know, >> Well, if you're not following Wolf
Gand. Okay. So, >> tickling the baby.
>> okay. Okay. >> Food Chops is talking. Yeah. Food
Chops is disagreeing with Mr. on who set a boundary between him
and Smith.
Um, so >> Yeah, that's the direction they're >> Okay.
Sure.
>> I am not comfortable with how this line is being crossed.
So therefore, I have to be able to set a boundary. But the way
that you set it for the baby.
>> I guess it depends. Are you talking about like if it
falls out of the carriage, would that be a boundary or is that
more of a >> um Are you pretending that you What? Listen,
I'm having a hard time maintaining this conversation and listening
to this, but like I'm following better than she is. That has
nothing to do with what he just said. >> Okay. If I go
into an airplane and there's a woman with a baby on the airplane
and I flick the baby's nose, whose boundary am I breaking? The
babies or the woman's? >> Well, you're breaking the woman's
boundaries of her emotions based on the safety of the baby, right?
>> Okay. Yeah, sure. I'm also breaking the baby's I'm kind
of breaking the baby's boundaries cuz I know it probably doesn't
want me to do that. No, boundaries are set by the person who
is making the boundary because they feel like they're uncomfortable
by something.
>> Okay. So, if I go onto a subway and quickly a woman
before she even has time to realize what's happening, I'm not
breaking her boundaries because she didn't have time to tell
me not to. >> No, typically there is a mutually
assumed set of boundaries.
>> Well, not even a boundary. I don't think Sorry, I can't
take it back. I >> No, stop it. It's all semantic and this
is all What is your [__] point? I guess I kind of
disagree with your word, the way that you kind of use boundary,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong. Um, but it seems like you're
more of setting a rule, right? >> A boundary is a type
of rule.
>> Yes. But it's less of a boundary because typically boundaries
in relationship is like, okay, don't come into my room without
knocking. That is
>> so here the verbalizing it literally doesn't matter.
It's not it. So would they both acknowledge that Smith is not
verbalizing the boundary, right? I think they're pretty clear
that Smith's not verbalizing the boundary. Mr. Girl's assertion
is that Smith can't verbalize the boundary, but that the boundary
exists if I'm following correctly at >> A boundary, right?
Because if I come in without knocking, then it is >> Yes.
But you already you already explained that. You already explained
>> as in like Smith probably understands that the boundary
with him and Mr. is like actually healthy, but
but he can't b he basically like he still doesn't like it. He
still he there's like multiple levels of like he he is engaging
with the fact that he understands why it's there, but he doesn't
really like it. And so it doesn't matter whether he's verbalizing
it or not. Sorry. Anyway, you sorry that was in response to a
chat message that just said a boundary doesn't exist if you can't
verbalize it. Smith doesn't have to verbalize it. It's been verbalized
for him. in this a boundary set on behalf of someone else is
really a boundary about yourself and how you feel about that
person and their wellbeing. So we can if you want to use that
definition which I don't really think is great but it still holds
it's still logically sound like why can't my 2-year-old child
jump off of a cliff? Well because it will make me feel bad so
that's why you're not allowed to do it. That's fine. It's still
my bary and I would still enforce it. Do you think that in language
there should be a distinction between somebody who is setting
something because they aren't comfortable with somebody else
versus you kind of um indulging yourself in the violation of
a social norm. For example, the woman before you get onto the
plane. The distinction between >> it was a subway.
Why aren't you following any of these metaphors? >> Intentionality.
The source of the >> No, I think you can safely assume
other people's boundaries
include not ring them. And so when you break them, you're breaking
their boundaries even if they haven't specifically told you not
to. >> If you assume that um boundaries are more of a um
inclusive of like society's norms
of not kind of like intruding onto someone's personal space,
>> then sure. But it's more of the sense that yes, there
could be a woman who expectedly wants to be before you get onto
the plane. However, you would assume that most people's boundaries
is that they don't want to get before they get onto the plane.
>> I agree. >> Um, you're assuming a boundary. Sure.
Based on
most people's perceptions of what that specific boundary is for
society, right?
>> So, I think that there should be a word for that social
norm of something else. It can just be it can just be goooo.
And then the boundary word can just be gaga.
>> But when I think of boundary, I think of two people
in a relationship and this person is uncomfortable. So therefore,
okay, that's why I said the boundary. If you specifically define
your boundary as I am unc >> um just to clarify, I think
she's basically saying that an assumed boundary that hasn't been
clarified yet is not as strong. If you violate that, it's not
maybe she hasn't said this, but it would be like it's a less
strong boundary. As in, if I've verbalized something that is
a social norm, that is like a stronger boundary than one that
hasn't been verbalized at all. I don't know what purpose this
serves. I don't actually think it probably serves any purpose
at all, but that is the direction she's going >> comfortable
by Smith's intrusion into your, you know, crossing of the circle.
Right? For example, if
>> Sure. Okay. You already you already addressed your own
question. If you're uncomfortable on someone else's behalf, not
on your own, is that a boundary that you're setting to protect
another person? Is it goooo or gaga? If I'm if I feel uncomfortable
because uh a baby
wants to crawl off of a cliff, am I setting a boundary on my
behalf or their behalf when I say don't do that? >> I think
I have to bite the bullet on like you're setting the bullet for
your Sorry, not the bullet, the boundary for yourself because
you're not comfortable with the baby being >> falling off
of a cliff, right? And in this definition, my boundaries about
Smith are on my own behalf because I'm not comfortable about
harm coming to him because of our relationship. >> Are
you analogizing
anal you're comparing? >> I was saying I was reading I
was talking to Shayen. I was reading something out loud earlier
today and I ran into the exact same word and I was like I actually
don't know how to say this word. I think it's analogizing but
I don't know.
>> is it analogous or analogy? But I think it's analogizing
but I don't know. >> Okay. So, specifically in Smith's
case, >> would you say that like he is
>> See how I got there with like no, >> I just listened
for like two seconds and I managed to get there. >> How
much How much >> You guys have been watching me the entire
time this was live, by the way. So, you know, I didn't pre-watch
this. >> Autonomy does Smith have to zero. >> Although,
I did [__] up Emory trying to kill himself earlier
or thinking about killing himself. So, maybe I'm not the best
listener either. What do you mean? I don't know how to quantify
I don't know how to quantify autonomy.
>> Uh the autonomy that he has in your relationship with
him. >> He has a lot of autonomy, but he doesn't get to
control what I do. I can set whatever boundaries I want. I I
we both have autonomy. So, I can do or not do whatever I think
is appropriate.
>> At least it feels like me that if I were to set for
example Smith as an adult, right? a few words to set about
>> and then
think of it as like this is one of my only
did in our talk.
>> What if
you say the boundary is I must rape you before I got onto the
plane because
I have to step for you. A boundary is about something you're
not willing to do or not willing to allow to happen. >> Oh,
audio got up. How what could it possibly Dude, Hold on. >> Okay,
I can change it. >> Is it fine now or is it
>> I don't think if you set a if I set a boundary that
contradicts the boundary of another person, then I guess we have
some kind of problem. But in this case,
um it just goes down to control. Smith can't make me communicate
with him in a way I don't want to. >> Okay. Um it's not
from the Rumblebod cuz my audio is fine. Weird. I see your point.
Uh it's a not not a do. Not to make people do something. You
are pushing them away. In that case then what if you set a boundary
for somebody? >> Sure. What if you set a boundary for >> Hold
on. I have to go back now. Sorry. I have to to follow this conversation.
I have to turn my like autism detectors all the way up to like
maximum sensitivity.
And I like literally if I miss like three words, I'm going to
be lost to happen. How how tough is this? >> I can change
it. I just want to >> I don't think if you set a if I set
a boundary that contradicts the boundary of another person, then
I guess we'd have some kind of problem. But in this case,
um it just goes down to control. Smith can't make me communicate
with him in a way I don't want to. >> Okay, I see your
point. Uh it's a not not a do. Not to make people do something.
You are pushing them away. In that case, then >> what if
you set a boundary for somebody? >> Sure. What if you set
a boundary for somebody where you go, okay, I'm going to keep
you from food and water
because it makes me uncomfortable. >> Again, I would say
that's a do and and not I think the default is that you don't
do anything and other people can obtain food and water as they
want to. So, I'm going to keep you from doing that. While it
that is a boundary, I don't think it's the kind of boundary you
could automatically
uh assume is self-protective in the way that you're framing my
other boundaries are the ones we're talking about. What if you
truly believe most people
>> whatever I believe in my heart if I say I will not allow
Smith to drink water
that's pretty different from there are certain types of conversations
that I'm not going to engage in with Smith because I don't think
it's appropriate. I I just don't I don't know that it's worth
the time that we're spending
teasing this concept apart when you probably just have a point
you could just say and I think you I think it's time for you
to just say it. What is your point? >> Sure. So I think
that when people think of boundary, it's something where it is
for their own safety. However, I feel as though you can kind
of manipulate the word boundary into like, okay, this is a rule
um I am setting for you, right? >> Um I think that when
people think of the word boundary, uh the thing is is that I
think it's you should allow SMF to set his own boundaries, but
if you're uncomfortable with something yourself that infringes
upon your emotions, you say, "Okay, this is a boundary that I
am setting against you, for myself." >> Do you think it's
possible for a person to set boundaries for the sake of another
human being?
>> You can set boundaries for yourself, for the sake of
another human being. Uh, you specifically I think Smith specifically
said for his own safety. >> Okay. If the thing that makes
me uncomfortable is that I think something isn't safe for Smith,
do you have some kind of problem with defining that as a boundary
I'm setting on his behalf
or for his protection? Do we really have to include every time
you do something for somebody else, I'm actually just doing this
because of how I feel about doing something for you? We already
know that. So, I don't that applies to every situation. It does
just it's just asking um she's saying she is suspicious of Max's
actual motive for setting that boundary. She's saying that Max
is setting that boundary because he thinks Smith is a gross weirdo,
gross weird freak that he doesn't want to interact with anymore.
And Max is saying, "No, I'm setting that boundary because I think
it's unhealthy for him even though I like him and I'd probably
interact with him that way if I didn't feel like it was dangerous
for him." That's that's the the discrepancy in the conversation
they're trying to have. >> Ever. If I hold the door open
for somebody, do I should I tell them when they say thank you
or should I say, "Well, actually, I'm holding the door open because
it makes me feel good to hold it open for you." So, >> I
mean, people are saying, "Oh, that that's probably true." I don't
think that's necessarily true.
I think like Mr. Crow's a weirdo. He might actually really like
Smith and he might totally believe this. It's like consistent
with all of the other ways he behaves, right? That when he thinks
he has like a moral right to do, he'll go to ridiculous lengths
to do it. >> You must be confused about what's happening.
I think everybody knows this on some level. I don't So I don't
think it invalidates the idea of protecting somebody else from
yourself in this situation. Holding a door, giving someone a
birthday present or whatever, whatever it is. Yeah. Everything
you do is on some level about how it makes you feel. That's true.
But I don't think it
>> if I were to say >> the boundary is that Max doesn't
feel comfortable playing into Smith's delusions. I that could
be the case. I could see another case where he might think, "Okay,
I like hanging out with Smith. I like having this kind of conversation
with him, but I've noticed when I have this kind of conversation
with him, it puts him in a mental state where he stops doing
things in his life that he needs to do to be happy. So maybe
he stops focusing on his own work or his own stuff and he starts
obsessing over our conversations. So that's not a delusion. It's
just Smith's behavior after they have certain kinds of conversations
might be become like negative for Smith. So it's not that Smith
is deluded. Max may actually fully enjoy those conversations
and like being super weird with Smith. That might all be really
nice for him, but he might actually No, it's not potato potato.
Those are not the same thing at all. It's that this kind of conversation
can lead to bad patterns of behavior for Smith that aren't diluted.
They're just Smith having like a a unhealthy relationship with
certain topics or an unhealthy relationship with um with like
his own thought processes.
say
something along the lines of because
>> Smith was typing in stream chat he was upset Mr. Girl
wouldn't rap him. Okay, that's weird. >> It infringes on
my own emotions then okay I set that boundary for myself against
you again like I said before, >> Yeah, but why would you
would you say that to a 2-year-old who's falling off of a cliff
or would you just say I care about you so I'm not letting you
fall off that cliff? >> Well, it's just more about I care
about you, right? you're preventing that person from physical
harm, but that doesn't mean that the boundary that the baby has
enough autonomy on their own in order to determine what kind
of boundaries it wants. I think that that's just more of a practical
matter of care than anything else. But when you are saying that
you're setting the boundary for somebody else in a relationship,
you're basically saying, I don't think you have enough autonomy
for yourself, and I think that you should have set this boundary
a long time ago or recently for yourself, but I am setting it
for you because you're a baby. >> I think you're misunderstanding
them. I don't think Smith should set boundaries in our relationship
about this
uh topic. I don't think I don't think that's about how we communicate.
I don't think that's his role. >> He can set boundaries
about how I communicate with him, but I don't think he should
set boundaries. I don't think he is in a position to
Okay, when you're in a relationship with somebody who is more
powerful than you, what you want is usually something abusive.
So, you want to be friends with your therapist. You want to have
with your teacher. You want your nurse to give you a hand job.
Whatever it is, you want more. But that more isn't good for you.
You want your dad to be your >> That's
you. Okay. You mean somebody you pay for, right? >> Your
dad is not someone you pay for >> for services. >> Jesus
Christ. >> Does she pay her dad? I don't I mean,
she's not listening at all >> cuz I'm thinking of therapist.
If you want your your older sibling, >> you don't pay your
teacher either. At least not directly. >> Your mentor,
your adviser, whatever, whether you're paying them or not. >> And
is your goal to prevent that abuse? Yeah, a lot of my policies
having to do with my community and how I interact with other
streamers,
especially those who look up to me or look to me for support
or guidance are aimed at preventing myself from being abusive
to >> Are you saying that you as a creator are unable to
make friends with your fans? >> absolutely. You can't be
friends with your your fans. No, not truly. Yeah, I don't think
you can be friends with your
>> You're cons. >> That's not true, guys. Anybody
who donates at least $10 to me in the next 5 minutes is actually
my friend. >> About the parasociality relationship. >> No,
I don't think that's the >> why you can't be friends with
a fan. >> Yeah. Why can't a creator be fan? Uh, sorry.
Why? Why can't a creator be friends with a fan? >> Cuz
a fan creator relationship and a friendship are just mutually
exclusive. You don't look at your friends like you.
>> Liberal Chad, welcome to the Orbiters Club, buddy.
>> $10 super chat. What's up, >> Brandon Zero? Yes.
If you super chat $10, you can be Wolf Gang's friend, too. >> What?
Yeah. Yeah. >> That we that as well.
>> Oh, I forgot.
>> Um, okay. >> You need to go. >> Yeah. Well,
no. I have two more callers, so we got to get we got to get through
this conversation. Okay. What's your point? Okay. You think that
I'm setting bars real quick? No. No. No. No. Shut up. Shut up.
You I had enough of your You call in here. Obviously, you think
that I think Smith and I have a parasocial relationship. Smith
is obsessed with me and I think he's a loser who want to leave
me alone. And so, being a manipulative No. Shut the up. Shut
up. Being the manipulative sociopath that I am, I tell Smith,
I'm going to distance myself from you because it will be best
for you. And then Smith, the little that he is, believes me.
And then he goes around telling everybody, "Oh, Mr. Girl's protecting
me." But everybody knows that actually he's just a loser and
I don't like him. Is that your theory? Just say it. Just say
that. It's so much shorter than all this TV. Do you think that
if a baby somebody on a train while they're falling off of a
cliff that it's technically a boundary if you stop them? Who's
that for? Just say what you think. I think I think you can play
video games with SMF regularly and become his friend. So then
he is no longer a fan of you at that point. Just like the Gundam
figure. That's what I'm saying. >> That's when your therapist
or your dad or your dad. That's a very broadening definition
of >> just shut up. When your dentist or your therapist
or your dad says, "Well, I had control over you,
but what if
I'm no longer your >> Is this new? Yeah. This is from like
5 hours ago
>> and we just change it so that while you're sucking my
dick, I'm not your therapist. Why don't we just do that? And
and the thing is that you can't that the Smith's feelings about
me
>> and the way he looks or views me, his perspective of
me is not it's permanent. What if you got to know the person
who's that you're sucking better to the point where they're not
just the person who in which you're felating and they're more
humanized because they're more threedimensional to you? >> She's
like actually incapable of following the conversation. Like actually
just completely incapable.
This is like this is like watching like a deaf person respond
to somebody. Like they g they were handed a script and they're
deaf. She can't actually hear anything Max is saying and she's
just like she's trying to like half rip uh lip lip read but she
can't actually lipre and then she's just responding with like
the closest thing she can think of off of her script. >> That's
fine. Then I become
what all admired figures become, which is a figure you still
admire on some level but are greatly disappointed by >> and
that's good. >> Yeah. But that doesn't change the relationship
and it doesn't change the boundaries. Boundaries are road away
and they don't really need to exist anymore once you are more
comfortable getting to know somebody, you know. >> No,
I don't think you should your kids even if you're 90 and they're
70. I still think you have an obligation to play a certain role
in their lives. And I and same thing with exatient. I don't think
therapists should date their ex-patients. Part of part of what
protect part of what protects meth now is the knowledge that
I will never budge on this. So if I hint to him, well, yeah,
I'll protect you from emotional or psychological abuse now, but
later we'll be buds. That is abusive.
Anything other than a promise that this will never change is
abusive. >> I play Hell Divers with my viewers and um I
reveal more things about my life
>> Congratulations, Wolf Gang. She just ruined it forever.
I'm uninstalling the >> Wait, I trust their fake. >> You
keep some of these parts private when I'm revealing these as
well as vice versa. I consider them to be friends at this point.
>> Am I my viewers? >> A little bit. then that is
an acceptable form of
>> good for you. I am aware that I have a
magnetic
presentation and body of work that lends itself to people regarding
me very highly in ways that it would be irresponsible of me to
ignore or not acknowledge and pretend we can just be friends.
As much as I want my friends to think I'm the bee's knees, they
don't. They don't. I think Smith will see you as a person if
you guys play Hell Divers >> That would be an abandonment.
>> Smith sounds like >> I don't even know this guy.
>> Hey, you do don't want to be Smith. Okay, you don't
want to be Smith.
>> Very narcissistic indulgence
at the expense of another person. >> He's just a viewer
that really wants or a friend that really wants to play with
>> Emotionally suffers over this from his posts. Unless
he was lying and just drumming up attention for a controversy.
>> I don't think you understand his posts. He's talking.
He's he's I think on some level he's bragging about how well
I treat him. I don't think he's
like
yeah nobody wants to be held at bay but at the same time he's
saying that it creates safety for him. I I the agony of like
a 13-year-old who wants his nurse to give him a hand job is not
yes it's suffering but it's not suffering that we need to like
fix through abuse. It's okay for people to want something and
not get it. >> Not donated $10. Are you aware of the best
girl edit ever? Ants, check
>> that's if you don't have that, then you don't have >> Sorry,
I was listening to TTS there, >> I'll actually Sorry, I'll
start saying TTS when I pause for TTS. >> The vibes I get
from the post is that he's suffering. The thing is is that he
will suffer no longer
>> if you just represent >> if you just a little
bit more. There's an old saying to it fullest extent. >> There's
an old saying >> you're um changing your relationship with
me. I don't think I can convince you, but >> No. No. You're
trying to expose me. You're trying to expose me as a liar. Yes,
you are.
>> Yes, that is. >> I just want to know your thought
>> No, you don't want to know your >> No, you don't.
These are questions that are not designed to know my thought
process. You are trying to expose me as a liar cuz you don't
believe you don't believe that people can hold boundaries truly
for the benefit of another person. You think of something that's
no longer a boundary. >> I cannot continue explaining this
to you. I must I must end this conversation. Do you have a final
thing you'd like to say? >> Yes. I enjoy this. >> It's
cuz you're sick.
>> H. Okay. >> Not funny. Not funny. >> It's
kind of based. Okay. It's kind of
>> Wait, what did you just say? >> She said, "I enjoyed
this." And he just replied, "Because you're sick." >> Go
back. Hold on. >> I cannot continue explaining this to
you. I must end I must end this conversation. Do you have a final
thing you'd like to say? >> Yes. I enjoy this. >> It's
cuz you're sick. >> I'm not. >> You're deeply sick.
>> I don't think I don't even know if he had the right
read. She might have actually been too in that conversation for
him to get the right read. Like
she did think what I said, but I don't even know that she was
trying to expose him as a liar.
Like I I don't know what her actual motive was there because
she wasn't listening or like engaging with anything he was saying.
She was just like >> [__] content brain. She
just wanted to get him. I'm pretty sure he read her
>> Well, sorry. I think she might have thought, "Oh, I'm
going to expose that you don't understand why you set this boundary."
That might have been I'm saying I don't think she collected any
information that conversation and change. I think she just someone
said it. She had like a script written when she came in. >> Oh,
yeah. And like that was all she was she was just going off the
script and that was it. This is like not interesting. Tech Katie
comes on later and talks about that call.
Tech Katie
>> Max won't let me have a phone and refuses to let me
let him rape me even if I had poison in my >> Good job
DFO75. >> Okay. Max is forcing me to rape him because he
won't let me let him rape me. It's the only way to get my phone
back. I'm typing this on the neighbor's iPad. I have to go. Yeah.
It doesn't It just feels like people just like don't believe
in boundaries. Who are you?
>> Who am I? Oh, >> but stop having usernames where
people have to sound out. >> Give me one second. I got
to turn on my >> say the letters and numbers. >> I
just moved. I have a whole new set up and stuff. So, it's a little
tough. >> It's wild that he just reacts to the TV. >> Oh,
it's Drowsy.
>> Literally every one of Was Smith on.
If Smith was on, okay, we can skip the DZY call. If Smith was
on, then all of the usual suspects made it on. Strayzy. Drowsy.
Katie. >> I'm going to talk to chat until you're
>> Yeah, I'm skipping a kitty. >> I can't foresee
if it'll be about Lollcon or Israel. I'm leaning towards Israel,
but I don't know. Um,
>> I'm going to self emilate if Mr. Girl doesn't stream
twice a week. >> There's something um >> there's
something about the self- emilation. I think that Twitter
especially, but social media in general, people brag about not
caring about 9/11,
whereas when 911 happened, you'd brag about caring about it.
But now irreverence is such like a desirable quality in a creator
that so much of the images I see of the self emilation are people
bragging that they are not emotionally moved by it which is like
the opposite of what you would want doing that kind of protest.
So it's very weird seeing that sociopathy
is like a hot commodity. I don't really get why that is. I guess
it's because the rule I think it has something to do with the
toos on social media being like you can't be a certain way and
southern people act out like like kids in school you know they're
the class clown is funny because they're flouting the rules but
whatever it is I'm doing >> seems really bad >> how
do I capture Discord Jesus Christ
um >> how do you capture in Discord >> yeah it's
like not showing up for me >> did you pop me out into my
window >> it's that Katie like the with the shaped head
and the was [__] insane >> I Let's pop you
out. >> Yeah,
do it. >> After you talked about Elder Drazzia rap you
and you smith, the least I could do is pop you out. >> Thank
you. That's very courteous of you. >> I'm not going to
rip you. We already discussed that. Why are you not working?
>> Do you guys think it'd be corny to just totally rip
Max's setup like one to one? Like just uh grab a old CRT on a
stand and use the same setup? >> I've considered the same.
It's so good. It's and it's it's even more reactive because I
guess it was Elder Drazzi that just showed up and he wasn't expecting.
So he literally just looks at the TV like it's a person next
to him and it adds so much personality. It's really good. I would
not blame you. >> I think the setup's amazing. I've always
thought the setup was amazing. >> Either way, it's not
Israel or uh Loi. >> Okay. What's up? >> Oh, okay.
So, two things. Foods came on
>> and uh I did not like you guys' conversation. I think
you'd agree with me but I just want to run through this. So I
think the way the internet and I guess people off the internet
therapy speech is so common now um have taken the word boundary
and just mean it to be anything is like really unhelpful. So
I'm going to tell you my conceptualization and you tell me if
you agree with that or if you use a different thing.
>> So as far as I understand it boundary is something that
you impose on yourself. I.e. When X happens, I do X action or
sorry, Y action. Everything else is rules that you set for other
people regarding how they should treat you. So, for example,
you guys use the analogy, that wouldn't be a very successful
one. But if I said someone a rule, don't DM me after 3:00 a.m.
My boundary would be if he breaks my rule, I will. >> Yeah,
that makes sense. So, I feel that the reason why people use boundaries
to mean >> Dude, I just had like a a brain blast for an
idea, though. If I if I did do a setup, if I wired up like um
if I wired up like an array of monitors, like I don't know how
you would do this. You'd probably have to like I'm not sure how
you'd do this. you probably have like a big
like a big monitor field that you'd split between different displays,
but if you could wire up like a couple not not uh not CRTs, but
like LCDs or whatever behind you >> and just have like
everybody's face from the Discord on each one.
>> So, it' be like you and like your panel of people behind
you. Yeah, like flat screens behind you just sort of like orbiting
around your head. So, while you talk, it's like your camera is
full screen like this, but you just have like the Discord cameras
of the other people who are in the call. Yeah. You just have
like a panel of not a panel, but like um I think I think that
would be really cool. I don't think it' even be that >> Yeah.
You're kind of talking about um like weather people how they're
standing in front of like a monitor
but >> almost but individually wired. I'll try to find
a picture that could like give you an idea of what I'm thinking
of. Anyway, I just I describe it. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know how
to describe it without taking away all the fun out of it, but
like a Zoom meeting and the main host is like live like in the
spot and everybody else is like a Is that what you're talking
about? >> Kind of. I'll I'll figure out I'll I'll explain
it to you guys. >> rules is because boundary sounds more
valid and like um like good than just acknowledging the fact
that we all follow established social rules and we all set rules
for each other all the time. I think there's a assumption of
goodness smuggled in with the idea of a boundary where if I say
I have a boundary that if Shayen makes eye contact with me I
will yell at her. >> You'll punch her in the face. >> Yeah,
I'll punch her in the face. Like is that really a boundary? Like
technically it meets the definition of boundary but no one would
call that a boundary. So I think that >> Well, I would.
It's just an abusive boundary. Your boundaries can be abusive
depending on the actions you take to enforce your boundary. I
just think that's part of the definition that needs to be ironed
out is that some people would say an abusive boundary can't be
called a boundary and other people would say anything could be
a boundary but some boundaries are abusive. >> Okay. Um
I that's that's a correct. So I think boundaries can't be abusive
but the the when you say I will do X action to enforce my boundary.
Those actions can be abusive.
>> So you can make any decision you want. A a thought in
your head is not abusive. It's just a thought. But what you manifest
to the world, >> it would be like the Matrix multis-creen
background. Yeah, pretty much. Not quite. I I'll try to find
it. It would be like the operator's chair, but you'd be facing
like the opposite direction. So, I I'll play I'll try to find
a picture of what I'm thinking about. >> Can be abusive.
>> Okay.
Boundaries can be abusive. >> The boundary itself is the
line I'm drawing. And then when you cross the line, what I do
that is packaged with the boundary is not actually part of the
boundary. It's it's a response. It's the enforcement of the boundary.
>> Exactly. And and the and if you call it an enforcement
of a boundary, that gives you more validity, right? Like my wife
didn't make dinner for me, so I disciplined her by punching her
in the face because that's my boundary, right? But no, that's
abuse your boundary cuz with enforcement of boundaries as well,
the difference between
Is this talking? >> I didn't I didn't mute. Sorry. Be like
this. But imagine the person was facing like towards us. >> This
would be like behind you. >> Oh my god. No, you should
still face that way so that there's still no face >> Oh,
face. >> Oh, that would be that would be that would be
fun. That would be >> You stream in this direction for
like maybe a couple months till you reach a sub goal to turn
around. >> That would be also very funny. But I feel like
eventually I'd like turn a monitor off and then you just see
my face in the in the black of the monitor.
Then it'd be dead. Anyway, that would be way too much work. I
just thought it was kind of neat. It was like an I thought I
had that would be way too much work >> between abuse and
like a valid boundary is that a valid valid boundary enforcement
would always be something that you enforce on the self. And punching
someone in the face is again like taking it out on someone else.
>> You could still you could just stop speaking to her
for a week. It's still abusive. I don't I think you can abuse
somebody even by self-imposed
>> Okay. So, let me challenge that a little >> I
think that with something like not talking to your wife for a
week, in that case, the intent really matters because if I had
a boundary where I'm like, if dinner is not ready, I'm leaving
him. That's not abusive. I'm allowed to leave any relationship
for any reason. Right? So, the distinct >> Okay, but but
we can talk about that later. My point is that the distinction
for me is like if you intend to punish someone else that's not
again a b an enforcement of boundary that is on you. You're you're
coaching on someone else. >> I don't I agree with
>> I think that in evaluating the abusiveness or validity
of a boundary >> audio up again. I don't know what's going
on with the audio guys. I have no idea. Is it still bad if I
pause it? Is it fine? Is it good? Is it good? Are you using voice
meter now? No, I don't know what's going on with the audio. That's
fine. have to feel it out for yourself and make some subjective
assessment because what if I'm just what if my experience listening
on my end at all? It's not the audio in the VOD either cuz I'm
not noticing anything. So, it's somehow happening in
>> Well,
I'm not trying to punish you. I just don't feel safe touching
you, talking to you, or sleeping in the same bed with you for
2 weeks every time you don't make me dinner. I would think that
from a third party who's like this guy's like abus he's emotionally
abusing you even if he doesn't know it still >> from a
third party but for me at least my conceptualization of >> the
window capture literally doesn't do anything BB poison I'm using
like an audio application capture maybe it could be that that
I'm not capturing all my audio through the same thing but there's
like a an application audio capture thing that I'm using is your
internet connection it is not >> of abuse is that like
you can absolutely feel abused and from your perspective it is
abuse but that doesn't make the person doing it an abuser necessarily.
>> I think it does. >> I just I just don't think
the I don't think the intent I don't think the intent matters.
>> I think the intent Sorry. >> I don't think the
intent can be the determining factor or a determining factor
in whether something is abusive. I think lots of the most the
things I would consider the most abusive are done with the purest
of intentions. >> Uh so I disagree. I think intent is not
the main factor, but I think it is a factor, but that really
depends on the situation. So, >> it's not a necessary factor.
>> Yes, I'd agree. Um, so two things. First of all, I wouldn't
mind like saying for the sake cuz obviously we could go around
and constructing theories. I haven't thought about this for too
long. So, for the sake of expediting the this thing because it's
not my core thing. Um, I'll say yes, some enforcement of boundaries
can be abusive, which would make the boundary semi-invalid. or
if their enforcement doesn't change then your boundaries are
abusive. Um but what interests me is that then do you agree that
in your conversation with food trucks when you guys both talking
about boundaries 99% of that conversation was about rules that
you set for Smith? >> No, they're rules I set for myself.
>> They're boundaries you? >> Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Boundaries.
>> Okay. Yeah. Okay. So what drove me crazy in that conversation
is that food like many other people are under this assumption
that like I can tell someone to do something and that's a boundary
that I have which is just not how boundaries work. >> Yeah.
It's about controlling your little >> Yes. And I think
people do this as well because the implication of so there's
the neutral version of we all set rules for each other all the
time and most of the time most of the rules we engage with are
actually preset for us right when we don't punch each other in
public that's because there's a social rule we don't do that
you don't need to tell someone on the street don't punch me but
is a rule not a boundary that you have um so I think when people
people use boundary instead of rule because rule has a con >> I
wonder if it max off when people do like the streamer thing so
lots of times I think what a lot of streamers end up doing is
they get used to reexplaining things because they're always concerned
about like people in their audience who aren't caught up on things.
You try to figure out how to start from zero a lot. And I feel
like Max probably doesn't have a lot of use for that. Probably
even less so now that he doesn't have all of his time to devote
to streaming now that he's like only streaming once once or twice
a week. Is it is it once a week?
But he's he's like not streaming as much. And so Katie's like,
why are you saying that like social conventions exist?
Like why how is that required?
itation of control. But there was something really interesting
the conversation with foods that you said or someone said in
our chat. If you can set a rule for someone whether they follow
or not decides who has power in that dynamic, right? >> I
don't know. >> Using the analogy, the rule is we don't
each other. But whoever then commits the is the powerful entity
in that interaction because they're the one capable of breaking
the rule.
>> Yeah. I mean kind of. Yeah. In the moment they are the
powerful >> in the moment. Yes. >> Yeah. Yeah. So,
so I think when we exchange the word rule for boundary is because
sometimes rules can be abused and who can set rules often is
tied to power dynamics and people don't like that. It complicates
their talks. >> Yeah. I don't think I've set any rules
for Smith at all. >> No, I don't care talking about Smith.
It just annoyed me like the the semantics that was all wrong
and very stupid. >> I don't care about >> Why are
we calling her foods? It's food shops. So if you say if the S
gets paired with food, then it would be food's hops.
I think if you want a nickname, it has to be food. Food food
>> Well, I'm in ESL and whatever is comfortable for my
tongue is what I do.
good. So, I'm glad you're on >> I want you guys all to
know that I'm continuing this under protest. >> Bored with
the rules thing because you were using boundaries a lot, too.
And I get foods where it was kind of very >> How could
you think I don't remember you? I've messaged you asking you
to come on my show. We've had a bunch of interaction. We've talked
like a few times. Is this We've added interactions on Twitter.
It's very weird that you would think I don't know who you are.
>> What do you want? Do you want my
>> He doesn't have any. >> Oh, I thought you were
talking to me.
>> Uh my Pringles is empty. Sorry. Um >> do that.
>> Usually I ask people if they remember me because assuming
that they're don't that they don't is vain and I don't like coming
off as vain. That they do. Sorry. >> Okay. So, you thought
I did, but you were just checking to for appearances. >> Not
for appearances. So, I have like kind of >> vanity like
an appearance. >> I had a certain uh Oh, we're going to
do therapy. Sure. This is you space. We'll do therapy. Um
I had a traumatic event when I was around 17 when that kind of
like changed my life for the next um
a few years after that where I've became acutely aware that sometimes
I can have a very I can think I know how things are. I can think
someone remembers me. I can think someone likes me. I can think
someone's into me. And then I'll act on it because I'm sure of
it. And it turns out that's not true. And when that happens,
that creates such immense amounts of like humiliation in me that
I could be so wrong that I then develop the coping mechanism
of continuously always dounding it even though people explicitly
tell me over and over again. And that way I never have to experience
that humiliation again. That's a long way to explain that you're
insecure. >> Can I go to my next point now or do you have
something to say? >> I get it now. >> Yeah. Um Oh,
but >> would being just saying you're insecure be enough
there? I'm not totally sure. >> I mean, some people will
be like, "Well, why are you insecure?" And then maybe all that
information will come afterwards, but I think if you just say,
"I'm insecure
when I'm not sure if people know me or like me." I feel like
that explains the same thing. >> I suppose. I don't know.
Anyway, um also guys, that's not Coke in that bottle. That's
water. >> By the way, you don't get to call me >> She
does chug like actual sugar like um full sugar coke like that.
Like she's chugging the water, but she's not doing that currently
>> on doing things for optics because the first public
engagement that we have, you acted a very specific way
optically even though we had interacted before. So
>> how did >> No, I've Sorry. I've I've actually
paused when she goes to take a drink and it's definitely water.
>> You acted like >> it only looks like Coke when
it's against her shirt. >> You don't know me and had no
reason to have any faith or trust in me >> Uh are you talking
about in that big group call? >> No, I'm talk >> I
think debate I was moderating with
>> Oh, I see. I think our first intera
clearly just water
>> was in uh you may not remember and this is very humiliating
for me but I think our first interaction was in a big group argument
uh like in January of 2022 or something like that. >> It
wasn't a group argument. It was a prime panel. >> Okay.
Yeah. Prime panel. It turn it felt like an argument.
And you said >> well you were mostly being racist.
>> Get on. >> Yeah. Yeah. And you said something
about us being or something right before. >> No, you like
to you like to weaponize the thing. And then you talked about
even if all black people would all the women, I would still not
support discriminating against black people. It was very >> racist.
That's very anti-racist. >> I'm not going into why you're
racist. >> I was playing I was playing chicken with Doobie
because Dubie was saying like every racist have a right to protect
themselves or from like interbreeding or something. And I was
saying that >> I do remember that interaction because well
it was one of the first debates that I remember cuz you were
just coming out and I was like oh god a panel with Duby, Destiny
and Mr. girl and I'm on it. And then like Destiny ignored me
and you talked over me and Dubie was being annoying and I got
to say three words. But I ended up doing a branch video >> Um
and I wanted to prove that Destiny also made um theoretical points
to why can theoretically be done ethically. Um so I I had to
clip that panel because that's the panel he was making those
arguments on. So I recently rewatched >> Okay. Okay. I
was like Jesus, you really remember this really well. This makes
>> Oh, I I also remember it really well because it was
very weird that Destiny said that. >> Is Katie winning
this? I think um she still hasn't gotten to her point. >> And
also you were being racist.
>> I uh I don't think I was being racist, but continue.
>> I think I'm almost never racist. >> I think I'm
not debating racism with >> Well, that's fine. But you're
just casually calling me racist, so I'm casually issuing a denial.
Continue. >> Good. You do you. >> And you do you.
We can talk about whatever you want. >> That's actually
interesting though. I just It just clicked for me. I think when
I say I think you're being racist or you are racist, people think
it's like an accusation that I expect them to um like fight against
when I'm just telling them what I think about them. Like I don't
I don't expect like a >> I understand. But I don't identify
as racist. Oh, I need >> That's okay. I don't care. >> I
know you don't care, but I >> Hey, man. I'm just You don't
have to disagree that you're a I just think you're a like why
would you disagree
about people calling me racist? If you call me racist, I have
to say that's a >> That's a No, no, it's a boundary. You're
allowed to call me racist, but if you do, I have to I enforce
my boundary by saying I don't think I'm racist. >> That's
very valid. >> That's me. >> Anyway, so >> I
did I did uh Sorry about the giggling. I I I I don't like you,
but I enjoy our interactions. You you you were friends with Destiny.
You know what it's like? >> to to think somebody's a bad
>> You can't laugh. You did this to Tom with the best thing.
Fest is like a super nebulous label. That's why it's funny.
Like a not a nebulous label and very very dangerous. And even
with the best thing, I I literally told them multiple times,
we can switch the name >> Bad person, but still enjoy their
>> I didn't think he was a bad person. And once I did,
I'd stopped enjoying his company. So, I don't think I don't think
I do know what it's like. >> Okay, then let me rephrase
because I said, "Yeah, casually." I don't like the whole thing
about I think you're a bad person. The way that I I So, the way
that I evaluate if people are bad people or not is like I look
at specific actions and I'm like, "Is this a bad action?" And
then if there's enough in the box, >> you have negative
influence on the world around me. >> What does that mean?
>> You think I do I make bad things happen or put bad ideas
out and I'm a harmful
>> Do I think you're a harmful person? Do I think you're
a harmful person? >> Well, it seems like I wasn't asking.
I just assume that's what you meant. >> All right. Um
so harm needs to be quantifiable and I think most people can't
be a harmful person to society or to their larger environment
like people can be harmful to each other interpersonally but
whether you're a harmful person like on a societal level I think
most people I I think like especially in the space of like content
creation I I think under a certain threshold of like popularity
and influence I really don't think you can call someone that.
So >> I think you were a lot more harmful when Destiny
was platforming you for example. >> Okay. So you think
I'm a bad person but I don't have the means to do bad things
cuz my platform is too small now. >> Do I think you're
a bad person? I think I explained my bad person thing. I think
Okay. Okay. Okay. I think you normalize abuse. I think you're
a racist and you sometimes say those things which emboldens other
people. >> What do you What do you think of a >> I've
heard you talk about black people. >> What did I say about
them? >> I'm not done with my list. Can I >> Why
did she turn into Why did she do baby words?
>> what else? Yeah. Anyway, I Which means that for me,
it's not about being a bad >> I feel like I get trolled
into watching this kitty talk. Why am I watching Katie at all?
>> Why did you guys troll me into watching >> I think
I'm doing with my wish. Oh, what were you saying, Sherry? Sorry.
He's the one who wanted to watch the Katie part. >> People
in chat said the Katie thing was good about >> like specific
areas that I think are
>> What did I say about black people as >> I don't
remember the specific. If you want to compile it and send it
to you, >> please do. I think that would be >> Okay.
My audio cut out there. >> Well, let me ask you this. Do
you think people can be racist against white people? Well, do
you think people of color can be racist against white people
in America? >> We're just asking about my definition of
>> Well, tell me about your definition of >> Uh,
just racial prejudice. >> Okay. Yeah, I think people can
be racially prejudiced for sure. Yes, >> if that's if that's
the the definition of racism you use and yeah, that's >> that's
the one I use. >> Yeah, a lot of libs do that. >> Well,
I don't like the systemic power differential definition because
there are so many different uh spheres of power that one finds
oneself in that to distill them all down to one seems >> you
shouldn't distill them down to one.
>> okay. So, Barack Obama can't be racist to his white
maid. Like, I think he can >> he can be racially prejudice
torture, but he can't have >> I get what you're saying.
I'm saying that if we think of the sphere that we're examining
as Barack Obama's house, black people have far more power than
white people. If you broaden the sphere to be the entire planet,
then you get a different answer. So, I think that it makes sense
to apply the word racist to any racial prejudice rather than
to bake into the word the size of the sphere that you're drawing
around the event. >> Okay. Two things and then we'll move
on. >> If you allow us. >> well, you explain why
you think. Okay. >> Barack Obama is a great example because
I would say Barack Obama has a lot more systemic power over a
white maid, but he doesn't have systemic power over a white maid
granted to him by his blackness. Right. That's why I say he has
so many compiling privileges and like power because there are
many axises of power that they basically renders him still more.
None of them are granted to him by his blackness. Any accesses
of power that they basically >> I don't know if this is
because maybe it's because I have it sped up that it's >> renders
him still more systemically powerful. None of them are granted
to him by his blackness. >> Have you ever been invited
to the >> Not to barbecue. Like >> when there's a
bunch of black people and then you you ever been in a room where
with you're the only person who's not black or 99% black people?
>> You're not sure. >> That room literally doesn't
exist in your mental hospital in Israel. Katie, I don't know
what you're talking about. >> It's okay if you don't know.
>> Okay. The second thing I wanted to say is that >> I
was want to know are you saying you don't know that's the answer?
>> Don't know what >> if you ever >> probably
I probably have been in a room >> but you don't know for
sure. >> I don't know for sure. >> Okay. In that
situation >> I I don't live in America. >> Oh, wait.
Hold on. There are like Ethiopian Ethiopian in Israel, aren't
there?
Maybe. Maybe that's possible. >> And I've never That's
fine. You That's fine. That's not You're not racist just because
you've never been that one person. But my point is that when
you're surrounded by black people and they're doing a bunch of
black [__] and they're saying a bunch of black [__]
and they're laughing in that black way and they're telling jokes
and they're all physical and black and then you're just there.
I would say there is privilege granted in that sphere to black
people to do say certain things, behave in certain ways. Come
on in, baby. >> Is it a systemic privilege? >> Yes,
it's a system of black people in the room of family. >> That's
not what a system is.
Families aren't systems. >> Families are systems. When
we talk about systemic privilege, we're not talking about family
systems. >> Oh, well, if we define systemic privilege as
excluding the system I'm talking about, then I guess you're right.
But if you don't do that and you listen to what I'm saying instead,
maybe broaden your mind for a second.
>> Well, you're out of control, buddy. We're supposed to
be on the call. >> You a long time you >> and you're
like completely flailing. And also, I'm gonna need to stop listening
to this and get on the call. So, you need to decide. >> [__]
Yeah. Make that graham crust. >> Can't do anything. >> Make
the graham crust. Yeah, you can. >> You don't need a wrist
to melt butter and mix it with the crust. >> It's a no
bake, Katie. It's a no bake >> graham crumble. >> What?
I'm talking to you. I know. I'm calling you, Katie. There's a
no bake graham crust. You just got to mix it with uh melted butter
and it hard. >> Why are you talking to me about that? >> So,
you know what the [__] we're talking
>> I have no idea what you're talking >> It's It's
barely cooking. It's just mixing butter with powder. And >> I
don't mix butter with powder. Well, that explains why you don't
understand black people. >> I wouldn't know why anyone
would think you're racist. Genuinely wouldn't know. >> I
don't either. Okay. I'll be there in a >> Can I trust you?
>> Okay. Will you really try? >> Okay. I'm not going
to listen to you >> Bye. I love you, too. Go [__]
yourself. I'll see you soon. >> A Okay. So, we don't have
time to talk about what I actually want to talk about cuz you
want to talk about racism. If a system can be defined as a group
of people with a set of intermingling relationships and values,
>> uh, I understand why you guys say this because uh, you
can only think in terms of things Destiny has said, but Katie
and Kelly are literally nothing alike
>> By that group of people, whether it's a government,
a town, a school, or yes, a family or a barbecue is a temporary
system. A social system is imposed in >> a social system
is not institutional. Again, yes, we can come up with a definition
of institution that excludes. It was a church. What about a black
church? Is that an institution? Stop making me come up with counter
examples to every possible thing you could say. >> No,
I I understand that. >> What about Yes. Yes. >> They
are absolutely different. >> Substantial doubt. You can
take another 24-hour break.
Well, not 24 hours. I'll do like I'll do like 18 hours so you
can come back at the next start of the next stream. Okay. Love
you, buddy. Have a good one. See you around. >> It's not
cognitive dissonance. What about a company that is run by a black
person and it has all black employees and one white person who
works there. >> I have an idea >> is blackness. >> You
want to talk about this? >> You've never spent time around
black people. You have never spent time around a large number
of black people. So you have no idea what you're talking about.
>> He didn't say they're exactly alike. He compared them
in a certain way. >> likes to be outnumbered.
>> You've never been You've never been the girl on the
couch in the meme. Well, I [__] have. So don't tell
me [__] about black people. I You don't know. You
just don't know. Okay. What do you want to talk about? >> Uh
don't don't you have to go for the call? Don't you have a call
to go to? >> Yeah, I got to play Smash with some friends.
But
>> what what do you want to >> Oh, yeah. All of this
was very yikes. But I do want to ask you this. You know how you
again in the conversation with with foods, you were kind of talking
about how you um can't be friends with fans and stuff like that.
Um but but you do agree that like these Collins
>> um are kind of therapyesque, right? >> They can
be. >> Okay. That interests me because you you were very
upset about the Dr. okay thing for doing therapyesque. And what
I'm confused about is like you can't be friends with a fan because
then you're them, but you can do therapy to a bunch of fans that
you have absolute power >> Yeah. Well, a therapist already
has power over you. So, it's not it's a lateral transition to
another relationship in which I have power. My problem with Dr.
K is that he was in a relationship where he has power. He is
licensed and therefore is un disallowed by the licensing organization
and by law from having relationships that are both therapeutic
and friendships. And so when he said literally, I don't know
if I'm your doctor or if I'm your friend, he's throwing him into
this chaotic state of confusion where yeah, he's he's being inherently
harmed by the blurry nature of the relationship. >> Put
Dr. K aside. >> Okay. With me and my So with me and my
fans, I'm in power as a creator or I'm in power as the person
you're spilling your, you know, talking about your trauma when
you're 17. >> No, you're both. You're you don't know if
they're your if you're their therapist or if they're their god
content creator. You're both. >> But either But either
way, the relationship is very similar. It's not it's not that
like I would I wouldn't I wouldn't have sex with them under either.
I wouldn't >> No, sure. I'm just I don't see how it's materially
different than the type of ethical consideration that you have
with being friends with a fan, especially when at least in a
friendship situation. Um, not that I'm trying to convince you
to play Smash with Smith or anything. >> do you see that
the power structure does not change? So, creator, fan, therapist,
>> this I'm not here. So, to me, the problem is when you
go creator, fan, friend. This is abuse when you switch like this.
Uh, therapist, patient,
>> playing smash. You know, you get what I'm saying? That's
the That's the problem is when the structure >> I do I
do know what you're saying. Okay. Still therapist. Oh, wait.
>> Um creator fan. >> Content creator. Therapist.
Fan
>> Yeah. But so yeah. So my concern would be is if I was
shifting from being on top to being lateral cuz then >> Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So you don't mind compacting more power
dynamic or compacting power privilege. You're just like you can't
go from having power over someone into having equalizing power.
But you can have more and more and more power over someone. >> Yeah.
I don't want to be the issue is this. I don't want to be in a
relationship with someone where we're pretending I don't have
power that I do. >> Okay. So, this this is the reason why
I said this conversation will come full circle for me cuz the
last time we talked, you exercised power over me and I got upset
and then I didn't enforce my boundary by leaving. I ended up
staying, which I'm very disappointed in myself for. But >> I
do think that in this case as well when you're saying that you're
you're not protecting anyone. You're you're doing a rule for
yourself, right? Like you don't want to be in a position. Well,
not just with Smith because it's not an ethical consideration
of, "Oh, I can't be going around Smith or fans because you don't
mind compiling power over someone as long as you remain the dominant
power holder." >> No. Well, are you asking me what you
think or what I think? >> I'm asking you how do you settle
the hypocrisy that I'm pointing out? >> There isn't. But
the thing I'm trying to avoid is the kind of abuse that happens
when you have a relationship where it's only appropriate to have
the relationship if you're equals, when you're not equals. So,
it's appropriate to be someone's therapist if you're not equals.
It's appropriate to be someone's content creator if you're not
equals. But it's not appropriate to be somebody's friend or partner
if you are not equals. >> Yeah. But it's also not appropriate
to be someone's god content creator and their therapist in front
of other people. So obviously some abuse you're not okay with
and some abuse you are okay with which is the hypocrisy that
I'm pointing out. >> Okay. Hypocrisy is an accusation that
by my own arguments and my own view that I am violating my my
own beliefs which I don't think is happening. It sounds more
like you're saying I'm hypocritical because I say I'm against
abuse and yet I'm in indulging in a type of abuse, which I don't
think is hypocritical. I think it's more just that you think
I'm wrong or just abusive. >> Oh, no. I'm saying I I wouldn't
I wouldn't think you are hypocritical if you said I'm not fine
with X type of abuse and I am fine with Y type of abuse. I I
would think that would make caring about abuse seem kind of silly
to a lot of people because it demonstrates that not all abuse
matters. But that's >> hypocrisy. It's hypocrisy would
be if I thought it was abusive and did it anyway. But I don't
think it's abusive. You don't think it's abusive to be someone's
content creator and their therapist in front of other people
>> I don't think it's abusive to be someone's content creator
and then have a conversation where they're talking about their
trauma in front of other people. I wouldn't call myself their
therapist, but for the purpose of this
>> which is why I asked you if you agreed that these conversations
do in fact cross into therapeutic lines. >> No, I don't
think they're actually therapeutic. No, I think they can be they
can be a little therapeutic, but they're not therapy. There's
not a expectation that we're going to keep talking or that I'm
going to follow up. And there's an there is an audience and there's
an expectation the conversation has to be interesting
maybe above all else. So >> how do you define therapeutic?
Sorry when I said therapeutic I I don't mean like that it's beneficial.
I just mean that there's a certain level of intimacy and engagement
in
>> very intimate and engaged but the the purpose of the
conversation is not to provide a benefit to the caller.
>> and do you think that's how the callers >> It
is a is a purpose but it is not the >> I feel like I feel
like she's going to make him stop doing Collins.
Katie, stop. This guy has like so few ways to make money. Please
stop >> the purpose in therapy. It needs to be the purpose.
>> Yeah, but earlier you even said that something that
abuse doesn't require intent. It doesn't matter what your purpose
is for a lot of people that come here to talk to you as as as
some form of therapeutic tool. It absolutely is, right? And you
know that you're not
>> Um I would
categorize that as them wanting advice rather than them wanting
to establish a therapeutic relationship with me. I don't think
people calling in think that we >> Yeah, I think it matters
a lot. I don't I don't think people calling in. It's like calling
a hotline. Like you're not trying to establish a relationship
with the person you're calling. You're trying to get help. >> Hey,
Veto just followed the channel. Interesting. What's up, Veto?
>> Or advice. So, I don't >> I think the dissonance
is how we define >> Uh, okay. You think therapeutic means
the person's calling cuz they want help. >> Hey, Veto.
>> No, I think so. A hotline is a really good example,
right? Well, there is no promise of continuality. the people
who are trained to do the hotline work are ethically bound and
trained to handle that emotionally sensitive situation. Um there
are rules they must follow. So while it is true that there aren't
like obligations of regular therapy, people understand that people
call a hotline for an for a therapy needing re therapy is the
wrong word but I'm trying to think of more anword distress. >> Okay,
again this isn't hypocrisy if we just disagree. So you would
need to show to call me a hypocrite. You need to show that I
think what I'm doing is abusive. So you can't compare to >> No,
I wouldn't because your intent doesn't matter. It's either abusive
or it isn't. >> Hypocrisy is a contrasting of someone's
belief system and then applying it to their own behavior. >> Yeah.
Okay. So, sorry. I'm not calling you a hypocrite anymore. >> Okay.
You're just calling me abusive. >> I Yes. >> Okay,
that's fine. >> Yeah. And I think other people by their
understanding of the metrics that you're using would see it as
hyp as hypocrisy as well because caring about one abuse and not
the other. But yes, I'm just calling you abusive. If you don't
think that this abuse is as bad as >> Yeah. I don't know
how he followed. I don't know what he was doing there. >> The
other abuse you'd like to avoid. That's like I don't care.
>> Um Okay. So, the question is, is it abusive for me to
allow people to call in seeking help when
uh the nature of the call-in show is such that they should be
talking to a therapist and not >> I can lay out why I think
it's abusive. Would you would you like that? I'll do it very
quickly. >> Sure. But I got to call. So, can you >> Yeah.
Yes. So, um people are calling and are being very intimate about
very personal things. This is done publicly with an untrained
professional and it impacts their life in significant. >> Why
are we watching this? Uh some cost
>> With the fact that the untrained professional is also
someone to have a parasocial relationship with. >> Untrained
professional. >> Use me. >> Sorry. Untrained abuser.
>> Okay. Well, >> uh to be cursed a bunch in his
thing. Rank these from most to least
I think. Hold on. Let me make sure I got those words right. Denims
Katie Frogan food shops. Should I be serious or should I meme?
Hold on.
>> Scallywag. We are not friends. Never were. You needed
to donate $20 to not be friends, so you didn't donate. >> Nobody's
scamming me into giving you >> Okay. Well, I'm just telling
you those were the rules that he laid out. All right. Although,
technically, you said Cherry has to opt out of my friendship
by me donating $20. If she doesn't, she's my friend. So, technically,
he has to donate $20. Wait, no, no, no. If he donates $20, you
opt out. But that's not really I don't know if that's fair.
>> I don't whatever. I don't care, dude. You could put
a gun to my head. I would tell you pull the trigger. I'm not
going to be your friend. >> Uh most to least I think food
shops most no frogan most food shops second most second
food shops most and then getting less as I go. Probably um
although Froen it's hard between Froggen and food shops. Okay.
They're the bottom two. And then probably Denims and then Katie.
Although they're pretty at least I think Katie might outside
of the absolute schizophrenia with which in in which she exists,
she might actually be intelligent in some ways with denims. I've
yet to see a spark. So anyway,
>> I don't know if I'm unra, but I got everything. Um,
yeah, people call people >> Denims and Froggen like literal
terrorists, lol. If you think that's the bar, I got some bad
news for you about >> Yeah, they could affect them a lot
and I don't know what I'm doing. That's >> You're doing
it publicly and you already have an established parocial relationship
with them. Yeah. >> Uh, the list was
food shops, Froggen, Denims, Katie, most to least. >> So,
I used to have a calling show called Advice and Confessions,
which I stopped because uh, somebody convinced me that I was
giving people an impression that talking to me would be like
talking to a therapist, which would actually discourage them
from talking to a therapist because talking to me can feel more
magical and fun and exciting because they're a fan of me, and
also because I have a knack for figuring people out really quickly.
But that's not really what therapy is about. It's not really
therapeutic. It's not that helpful. And because of that, I stopped
the show because I did I did think that was a good point.
>> how is this show materially different with its current
boundaries? Right. >> Well, callers are screened for immediate
psychological distress. They're also I mean, there's no way to
totally screen us, but they're asked if they've ever been institutionalized
or in a psychiatric hospital. So, we do try to screen out people
who are vulnerable. >> How'd Katie get in then? >> Um,
but if somebody calls and says like like memory call earlier
and he's like, "I'm being harassed. I feel like I feel scared
and unsafe." >> He was distressed. It was clear to everyone
and food shops was listening to it on his end making fun of him,
right? And he comes to you because he has a certain type of admiration
for you. And how how is that? And it also would be abusive to
just tell him, "Hey, you're getting too personal. I have to kick
you off now, right?" So, >> I don't know. That might not
be abusive, but I uh >> I mean, if that's a rule you wanted
to add to your show, I think that would still be >> I have
a kick. I totally I just believe you go. Okay. I I >> show
I'm trying to get through it. Okay. >> Some sort of ethical
lang around what's happening, but >> Uhhuh. Yeah. The show
is exploitative for sure. >> Um I don't know if that rises
to the level of abuse.
>> Okay, then that would then go to my argument as exploitation
abuse blah blah blah and you don't have the time. That's fine.
But if you recognize that it's exploitative, that's already like
>> um it's exploitative, but I don't know. Uh part of me
thinks it's exploitative and part of me thinks like um all this
this stops me from making movies with other people. I made a
couple short films and then it was awful. I was like, well, I
just have to get used to it. I audition people and I hated it.
I hated every second of having somebody read for a part. It felt
like I was humiliating them and I couldn't stand it. I just was
like, whatever, just read it and I'll just cast you. Like I I
can't I can't handle this. Um telling them what to do, splashing
them with fake blood. Every every part of it just felt like uh
incredibly exploited. But then like I love movies, so like I
don't know how to swear that. And the same thing with shows like
this. I'm like I like I've always liked relationship advice shows
and I've always liked calling shows. I've always liked public
conversations and so I on one hand I'm like well just >> why
are we still here? Because I'm going to finish watching this
Katy and then I'm going to sign off the stream. Okay. So I'm
just trying to finish cuz it feels really to not finish a video
after I've started it for people. Okay. >> It feels like
yeah anytime I work with other people in any form some on some
level it is exploitive and and so then it's like is it I'm playing
a game with myself like can I say >> yeah our own emotional
desires and passions are always hindered by ethics that we believe
in. Right. Like me going on to talk to you I at the beginning
I said I'm going to go talk to him cuz I think he's very good.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm not I'm saying that part of me thinks
all streaming is exploitative and wrong and then part of me is
like well I'll just try to do it in a way that so like I don't
allow super chats I turned off super chats on my site because
it just feels like a gambling addiction that people get into
and it's exploitive. I think it's wrong. I don't want to make
my money from super chats anymore. So I turned it off. Um I shut
down the show. You should not call in specifically because you
want this like therapeutic part of me to come out. But at the
same time, yeah, when you tell me I had this traumatic experience
when I was 17 where I got rop pulled, I think my demeanor immediately
changes where I am trying to take care of you and it's not it
just like happens and I >> I agree. Um but I I do think
that when I was telling it and that's the difference, right?
It was more of a story that >> No, every caller, no. Every
abuse victim thinks that they It doesn't apply to me. You can
have sex with me, teacher. Just I'm fine with it. It's the other
girls. It will be right. >> No, don't worry. That's definitely
not what I meant. You cannot have sex with me. Um, you get what
I'm saying that you >> I will address what you said. >> Me,
I talk now. >> Okay. Um, I get what you're saying. Uh,
I know you didn't particularly ask for my advice, but I I >> That's
kind of funny. Little bit bass from Katie there. Me, I talk now.
And he's just like, "Oh, all right." >> struggle with like
the same things as well. Um, like whenever I consider even talking
to Destiny, I'm like, "Well, I like I like having conversations.
I I want to go on panels and this and that, but I'm also like,
"Why, I think this is harmful." and then you're constantly limiting
yourself based on your perspective of what's harmful, right?
Um I think I do think it's interesting that you would rather
that you would think the super chats are more exploitative in
a different in a way that matters to you more than the type of
exploitation that's happening. But maybe I don't know you well
enough to know what your ethical priorities are, right? I think
at the end of the day it's about knowing your moral and ethical
priorities and just engaging in the lower levels of it because
you'd never be clean, right? But just make sure that like the
top stuff are not yikesy, you know? >> No, it's not. I
don't care about that. It's I think it's more that talking about
my self and opening up about my life is something I would do
and have done in interviews with people who were in control of
the conversation that I wasn't. So that's what we just talked
>> Yeah. Whereas sending so I'm saying that calling in
my own show is the kind of thing I would do but sending someone
to super chat so they pay attention to me for a second feels
like maybe I'll do that too but I don't think I ever have unless
I knew the person. So that >> but that's what I'm saying
that like you and and we just talked about it like if you just
added a rule to this show where it's like if I deem what I'm
saying
>> I the Jesus >> I view the show as something that
is harmful on some level to me and the callers and the sacrifice
we are all making is that something good might come out of it.
Sometimes something does so is exploitative and risky but I don't
think it's abusive. >> Yeah but you you did a thing there.
It's risky for both of you but it's more risky for them and it's
more exploitative towards them. You're not the one being exploited.
You're the >> in the Yes. Yes, I'm an exploer. In the short
term, it's more risky for them. I think in the long term, the
show probably harms me more than anybody >> That's fine.
That doesn't matter. >> It does matter >> uh to you.
I mean, like uh >> it matters to me. >> Yeah. I just
think that like a slave owner being very sad at the end of the
day, by the moral weight of the slave ownership, like I don't
really care, you know? Like I don't care about his suffering
because of it. He's the slave
>> Yes, I get that. But I
in order to make content or art that involves other people, I
I just have to accept a certain level of exploitation. every
interview subject, every podcast guest, every time I ask Shaylen
if she'll let me film her, I'm being exploitive and I'm putting
people at risk. >> Yes. But that's thresholds, right? >> Right.
And I don't think this meets the threshold for abuse. >> Okay.
I think that considering other thresholds that you've presented,
it does cross a threshold of exploitation that you say you don't
want to be a part of. But it's possible that with the constant
sacrificing of um exploitation for for like ethical reasons,
um those lines have changed and that's that's a you thing, right?
>> Right. Well, okay. Yeah, that's fine. I don't agree
that um I don't know what lines you're talking about. What? Destiny
like or Dr. K. I don't know what you're No, no, no. I mean like
>> super chats, dummy. Now he's not listening. Although
to be fair, Katie is extremely tedious. >> This show without
a rule that you at some threshold are like stopping and being
like this is crossing a line. You have to get out now is not
materially different. There is a point at which I'll tell someone
to get out. I just don't I just don't think that I we hit that
point today. It tells you're saying you think I should end the
call with >> I didn't even listen to the full call with
me. Emry doesn't like me, so I tried to >> Jenny doesn't
exist. >> Well, I definitely don't want to talk about him
then. Um or how I handle the call if you didn't hear it and you
have some like beef with him. Um, yeah, I'll think about this.
I appreciate the feedback. Is there anything else you want to
say? >> Have fun playing Smash. >> I will. Damn it.
>> Okay. You're racist. >> Keep it real. One love.
>> Disgusting. Bye. >> Bye. Okay. Well, >> scallwag
donated the moral.
>> My relationship with Cherry is an opt out relationship.
My relationship dynamics are exclusively organized via donations.
If you have something to negotiate, you'll need to find a way
to donate to me. Okay. Scallywag says that you guys are friends
and the only way he or he manages his boundaries around his relationships
is through donations. So if you want to change the fact that
your friends share, you have to figure out a way to donate to
him. Yeah. I don't understand it either. I'm just doesn't deserve
that power. Well, she's not the artist, but she's presenting
a challenge and we got to take it seriously. It's something I
struggle with a lot. I don't I don't know how to work with other
people without feeling like something horribly abusive is happening.
And it goes to the beginning of the show. Streaming is inherently
abusive. What does the audience want? Audience wants someone
to call and screaming and crying and throw themselves off a building
while streaming it. So if that's true, I don't know. Definitely
exploitative is abusive. I don't know. Don't let her hurt you.
She's doing something susceptible to implanting seeds of selfhate.
Yeah, definitely. There's like a I think after the Aerodite thing
where I was like in near tears hearing about this email somebody
from my supposedly from my community sent her. Uh and then just
seeing that like she has like zero qualms about just completely
on vulnerable people later. I I got to toughen up about the guilt
tripping. But then I but at the same time I don't >> Yeah.
Yeah. The he mentions me right away. I >> just don't want
to you know it's something I already worry about. So I'll have
to think about it. Maybe there's a new rule or policy that will
help, but I don't know. I never know what to do. I've been wrestling
with this part of our relationship, but I figured it out. It's
not if I give Max the look at the place at the moment when he
places his Gamecube controller at the entrance of my prime Nintendo
Switch controller port. I'm glad you figured that out, Smith.
Max, where these people come from? I don't know. Katie should
be your co-host. I don't. It feels like she It does feel like
she's like uh
pouring salt on my like guilt wounds. I don't think a co-host
ship is a good idea. >> After the Destiny attack, he's
gone into full coat mode. Everything is abuse on the internet
if you're profiting. So, you can't do that or else he's a hypocrite.
I don't think it's about profiting. I think it's about profiting
via donations from your viewers.
There's definitely something that could be abusive there, right?
Like, I don't know that everybody who donates to me is really
capable of making the don donations they make. They're like financially
struggling or something. There could easily be something abusive
there. That's not like a completely point or something. Just
comes down to like what's practical in a lot of ways. Like, is
it practical
to make sure everybody else around you, including people who
watch you, are taken care of? I don't know. Probably not, >> man.
There's this part of me that my chair is getting so squeaky like
now. It's like a few weeks old, few months old, and it's like
starting to get so squeaky. It's kind of annoying. I'm going
to have to tighten it up or >> Anyone, especially if they
look up to me. And then I'm like, "No, you're [__]
adults." I don't think the show is inherently abusive, and I
don't think it's pretending to be something it's not. The problem
is she would never hold herself to the standard she's holding
you. case in point, taking an underhanded dig at an at Emory
and figning like she cares about him. Yeah. I think another thing
is that like every I guess the food shops call also this that
I actually care about this stuff and then people think I don't
and maybe they don't and then it's just people trying to get
owns on each other and and and so then I engage and then I feel
like I don't know what I just I don't know what just happened.
Does she Is this a genuine concern? I don't know. I just I'm
getting jaded and cynical. There's a spectrum.
Yeah. Max grew up in the trenches. Yeah. I used to live in Harlem.
Did I have white privilege in Harlem when literally everyone
was black everywhere all the time? You go to the gym, it's like
chocolate factory telling me that I have systemic power over
these people. I'm a little marshmallow melting in a cup of steamy
hot chocolate. I got nothing.
My friend's uh uncle did own the building, but other than that,
>> I can confirm that not everyone in Harlem is black.
>> All right. >> Whatsoever the situation at all.
Okay. Thank you for watching Mr. Hotline. The next broadcast
will be uh Monday talking to Dick Mastersonson about a whole
lot of stuff.
Loi Black Holes maybe Maddox. See if he wants to talk about it.
>> That' be interesting. >> A new user named new
user. Hey yo, first time here. I've been listening to your music
on YouTube for a while and just searched you up and saw you were
streaming. I just wanted to say I appreciate your stuff and I'm
genuinely surprised at how underrated you are. I like you. Thank
you. Black holes is the name of like his physics thing. >> And
it's not Lolly Black holes, it's LO and black holes. >> I
don't know why we're going there. I think I think I have a new
song coming out in uh the next week or two. See how it goes.
I think I like it. If I like it, I'll release it, but I It's
just a little uh might be might be more than I don't know. It
feels like it's going kind of fast. >> Oh my god. I hope
this is the song that >> he said I'd be able to relate.
>> Music fans will be more. >> Which one? Oh, wait.
When did he say that that you'd be able to relate to it? >> Uh
cuz I replied to his current song and I was like, "Can you write
something I can relate to like for the memes?" Cuz it was about
uh black people >> black people. Yeah. >> Yeah. And
he said he he was going to >> Okay. All right. I just want
to hear the call out. And then >> Are there any Mr. Girl
live performances? I was thinking about that. I've never performed
live. I was thinking about uh actually in high school I I co-hosted
a freestyle battle and I and I did a rap as part of that, but
other than that, I've never
played music. Well, actually, that's I was in the jazz band,
so I played drums live, but I've never like wrapped live. But
I was thinking about >> You should do a Fortnite concert,
>> you know, as I get deplatformed slowly from every every
other medium. I might need to lean into music more, which might
mean might mean performing live. So, I might try it. Oh, I'm
being watched
by Jar. I'm watching you right back.
Oo, >> got my eye on you. >> Any news on a lab collaboration?
Uh, she might be backing out. >> You should take this Mr.
Girl call out and make it a soundboard or donation sound. It's
not a bad idea. >> Seems like maybe it's not going to happen.
I might have to just make the song without her.
>> Okay. What a great What a great stream. >> What
a great stream.
It's way too late for me to You know what? I'll tell you off
stream. It's all good. It's all good. I love you, buddy. >> Okay.
Um, >> lots of donations, lots of friends, >> lots
of friends, lots of brand new friends.
Dan wanted me to watch the clip that he had. I feel like this
is just the the like staring at the camera thing. I don't make
fun of the guy after just watching his uh him like do some good
content. Um,
I would need somebody to walk me through the logic of how I'm
wrong because the what I'm saying is not really about Wick's
thoughts or intentions. It's more about the function that it
has in a conversation. when the question like
if if if the report
it outlines there's an ant on my straw. Shaylen Shaylen there's
an ant on my straw. Uh, if the report details all the, you know,
these 15 stories of abusive behavior. Wait, what if the
what if the dust that came out of my rice bag that I was using
to heat my hands while writing the report, my hands were hurting?
The rice in here, I would microwave the rice, but then I crunched
it too much. And then some powder came out. I think there's powdered
rice on my desk from that. What if the aunt is here for that?
Oh god,
>> Um, he keeps calling it. I would need somebody to walk
me through the logic of how I'm wrong because the what I'm saying
is >> like someone wrote this. >> It's a it's a good
one. I enjoyed it quite a bit. >> It's like a written skit.
This is so funny. He call rules of three. He calls her like three
times and every time more exasperated. It's so good. >> Sh.
Oh god. It's good. It's good. Okay, there we go. There's a streamable
link in both both chats. Yeah. I just wish, man, I wish some
of these people could just like chill like 10%.
Just chill like 10%. You guys are so awesome.
>> About chat or is he talking about the people on stream?
>> Mr. Girl Lav
uh Queen too, if you guys could all just chill 10%.
So good. Just take 10% off. Okay, 10% off the top, you guys would
be fine. Anyway, okay. That Katie, that Katy talk took the soul
from me. Okay,
so I think I'm going to raid Veto if he's still alive.
on kick and then I don't know. >> Wait, didn't he just
raid you? Are you just going to throw it back to like hot >> No,
he he um No, he didn't raid me. >> Yeah, he didn't raid
me. Nobody's live on YouTube that I follow. Paragon content tomorrow
if he wants to come on. I I
listen felt kind of weird dodging tonight, but we'll see. Maybe
he'll be ready to go. Okay, maybe he'll be ready to go. Okay,
guys.
Thank you very much for coming to watch tonight stream. I enjoyed
it quite a bit.
I think I'll be back tomorrow. I was able to save my voice a
little bit, too.
Not Not quite as bad tonight after I'm done streaming. Yeah.
Thank you guys for showing up. I love you all. Oh, wait. I didn't
do the raid. Whoops. I am actually officially raiding Veto. He's
just playing, I think, Final Fantasy 7. Is this Final Fantasy?
Yeah, he's just playing Final Fantasy 7 stuff. So, I don't know
how long you guys are going to hang out there for, but I'm going
to rate him. >> Throw him a follow or something. Okay,
I love you guys. We'll see you tomorrow. Okay, have a good night.
>> Tomorrow. Good night, guys.